G.O.P., 19 SEATS THEY NEED TO
WIN THE MAJORITY AND PELOSI'S
SPEAKER.
WITH US NOW WITH MORE ON THIS AS
MINORITY LEADER KEVIN McCARTHY
McCARTHY.
EVERYBODY IN WASHINGTON HAS
CONFIRMED THAT IS THE NAME BEING
BANTERED ABOUT.
I CAN'T CONFIRM UNLESS YOU CAN
CONFIRM, IS REPORTING, BUT LET'S
STICK TO THE FACTS.
YOU HAVE HEARD THIS PERSON'S
NAME, CORRECT?
WE WON'T MENTION IT.
>> THE ONLY PERSON THAT CAN
CONFIRM THIS IS ADAM SCHIFF
BECAUSE HE IS THE INDIVIDUAL WHO
HAS MET WITH HIM.
WHAT IS INTERESTING, REMEMBER
ADAM SET AT THE BEGINNING OF THE
ADMINISTRATION WAS GOING TO HOLD
THIS WHISTLE-BLOWER BACK.
THIS QUID PRO QUO WAS IN THERE.
ONCE THE CALL CAME OUT AND WE
SOLD THE TRANSCRIPT, THE
PRESIDENT HAD DONE NOTHING
WRONG, NOTHING TO BE IMPEACHED,
BUT NOW THEY WON'T BRING THE
WHISTLE-BLOWER FORWARD?
WHAT DOES ADAM SCHIFF HAVE TO
HIDE.
ONCE AGAIN, HE HAS TAKEN AMERICA
THROUGH A NIGHTMARE BECAUSE OF
HIS LIES.
>> Sean: WHAT WE KNOW IS
BECAUSE WE KNOW THERE WAS
CONTACT, THAT IS A FACT, WITH
SCHIFF'S OFFICE, THAT WOULD MEAN
HE IS COMPROMISED.
THAT WOULD MEAN HE LIKED YET
AGAIN LIKE HE LIED THE LAST
THREE YEARS.
HOW COULD ANYBODY ALLOW THIS MAN
TO RUN ANY INVESTIGATION?
HE'S A BAD WITNESS.
>> HE IS A FACT WITNESS AND END
THE JUDICIAL SYSTEM OF THE FACT
WITNESS CANNOT BE A PROSECUTOR.
WHAT WE WILL VOTE ON TOMORROW,
NOT ONLY ADAM SCHIFF A FACT
WITNESS BUT A PROSECUTOR, A
JUDGE, AND A JURY.
HE HAS STOPPED PEOPLE, WITNESSES
FROM ANSWERING QUESTIONS.
SO HE OBJECTS, BUT WHEN HE
OBJECTS TO ANSWER THE QUESTION,
HE IS THE JUDGE WHO RULES
WHETHER THEY SHOULD ANSWER THE
QUESTION OR NOT.
HE SHOULD ACTUALLY SEND THESE
WITNESSES A LEGAL BILL BECAUSE
HE IS ALSO THE ATTORNEY.
HE'S THE ONLY ONE PICKING THE
WITNESS.
NOWHERE IN THE JUDICIAL SYSTEM
WOULD WE EVER ALLOW THIS.
IF THIS WAS IN A COURT OF LAW,
THERE WOULD BE A MISTRIAL RIGHT
NOW BASED UPON WHAT THE
DEMOCRATS HAVE DONE.
AND THE WAY THEY HAVE TREATED
ALL OF THESE FACTS.
IT IS THE PROOF OF THE POISONOUS
TREE.
IT WOULD BE THROWN OUT BUT ONLY
IN NANCY'S HOUSE DO WE RIGHT NEW
LAWS AND YOU GET NO DUE PROCESS.
>> Sean: LET ME ASK YOU THIS.
YOU KNOW THE IG IDENTIFIED THIS
GUY IS POLITICAL.
WE KNOW THAT THIS IS A HEARSAY
WHISTLE-BLOWER.
NOT EVEN A WHISTLE-BLOWER.
WE KNOW THE ATTORNEY GENERAL HAS
EXONERATED THE PRESIDENT OF ANY
WRONGDOING BUT MORE IMPORTANTLY,
HERE IS WHAT WE ALSO KNOW.
WE HAVE THE TRANSCRIPT, THE
TRANSCRIPT TO ME, NOT ONLY
EXONERATES THE PRESIDENT, BUT IT
SHOWS THE PRESIDENT BECAUSE
WE KNOW FROM UKRAINIAN COURT OF
POLITICO, THAT, IN FACT, THEY
DIDN'T INTERFERE 2016 ELECTION.
I THOUGHT THE DEMOCRATS CARED
ABOUT THAT.
WE KNOW THE PRESIDENT WAS DOING
HIS JOB.
IN OTHER WORDS, FAITHFULLY
EXECUTING THE LAWS.
WE KNOW THAT JOE BIDEN ADMITS ON
TAPE TO A REAL QUID PRO QUO MAY
EITHER YOU FIRE THIS GUY OR
YOU'RE NOT GETTING $1 BILLION.
THAT WOULD BE A QUID PRO QUO.
WE KNOW HUNTER BIDEN HAD NO
EXPERIENCE IN UKRAINE OIL, GAS
ENERGY AT ALL.
BUT HE GOT PAID MILLIONS.
HOW DO YOU DISMISS INVESTIGATING
THAT?
HOW DO YOU DISMISS COMPROMISING
ADAM SCHIFF AND IG REPORT AND
THE WHISTLE-BLOWER REPORT
COMPROMISED?
>> IF YOU ASK THE AMERICAN
PUBLIC, THEY WANT TO SEE HUNTER
ACTUALLY INVESTIGATED BECAUSE HE
GOT PAID AND THERE WAS AN ACTION
TAKEN.
NOW, ALL THE VIEWERS HAVE TO
UNDERSTAND WHAT ADAM SCHIFF HAS
LIED TO US ABOUT AND WHY THE
PRESIDENT HAS DONE NOTHING
WRONG.
THEY HAD A PHONE CALL ON
JULY 25TH.
THE MONEY WAS SENT ON
SEPTEMBER 11TH.
UKRAINE DID NOTHING FOR THE
MONEY TO BE SENT FORWARD TO.
SO THERE IS QUID PRO QUO SO WHY
ARE WE CARRYING THROUGH WITH
THIS?
YOU KNOW WHY THEY CAN T -- KEEP
IT IN INTEL AND NOT JUDICIARY?
BECAUSE THAT ALERT IS A FAILURE
AND SHIFT HIS EIGHTH FRAUD AND
WILLING TO LIE TO THE AMERICAN
PUBLIC.
>> WE ARE TAKING A VOTE
TOMORROW.
NO DEMOCRAT SHOULD VOTE FOR THAT
BECAUSE THEY WILL TRY TO JUSTIFY
ALL THE ACTION TAKEN AND THEY'VE
NEVER EVEN READ ONE TRANSCRIPT.
>> Sean: IS THERE ANYTHING YOU
CAN DO AS HOUSE MAJORITY LEADER?
I'M SORRY, HOUSE MINORITY
LEADER.
SOON TO BE.
>> YES.
>> Sean: BUT IS THERE ANYTHING
IN YOUR ARSENAL THAT YOU COULD
DO WITH YOUR ENTIRE CAUCUS TO
MAKE A STATEMENT AND STOP THIS
TOMORROW?
>> WELL, YOU WATCH WHAT WE HAVE
DONE TIME AND AGAIN.
WE WILL CONTINUE TO FIGHT EVERY
STEP OF THE WAY.
BUT AT THE END OF THE DAY, WE
LIVE IN A RULE OF LAW AND 20 --
218 IS THE ROLE OF LAW ON THE
FLOOR.
WHAT NEEDS TO HAPPEN NOT JUST
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE NEEDS TO
JOIN WITH US.
IF YOU BELIEVE AMERICA IS MORE
THAN A COUNTRY.
WE HAVE TO HAVE DUE PROCESS.
PICK UP YOUR PHONE NOW.
CALL THOSE DEMOCRATS AND ASK,
WHAT IS THE IMPEACHABLE OFFENSE?
WHY CAN YOU VOTE AND NOT HAVE
DUE PROCESS WHERE REPUBLICANS
HAVE GIVEN IT TO DEMOCRAT
PRESIDENT AND DEMOCRATS HAVE
GIVEN TO REPUBLICAN PRESIDENTS.
WHY TODAY IS DIFFERENT, WHY ARE
YOU PUTTING THIS COUNTRY THROUGH
IT AND WORST OF ALL, WE ARE
ABOUT ONE YEAR AWAY FROM A NEW
ELECTION.